welcome to the David Pacman show I am
not David Pacman and while you may think
that I am an out of work Jim Gaffigan
stunt double I am indeed Jesse dalamore
host of the dollar more daily on YouTube
this past Friday
a the the the the the brutal beating
tape of uh Tyree Nichols was released
the brutal beating that took place at
the hands of the Memphis Police
Department
an elite group of police officers the
most highly trained on their staff took
part in the beating that ultimately led
to his death I'm not going to play the
footage here it is out there it is
public you can find it on Twitter really
anywhere you just do a Google Search and
you'll find it
foreign but I want to talk a little bit
about what was released and the timing
of the release on a Friday night it
seemed
strange to me and then we're going to
talk about some ghoulish takes from the
right notably Fox News and Jesse Waters
first though if you haven't seen it it
is gruesome and and
the lack of humanity that was displayed
will rock you if you are not careful
about how much you consume of it
disgusting just a complete disregard for
the life and well-being of Tyree Nichols
it also goes because they were in
the Scorpion unit which has now
apparently been disbanded but they were
members of an elite police unit and it
was like the Keystone Cops
they were pepper spraying one another
they were injuring themselves while
trying to administer a brutal beating on
this civilian on the citizen on this
uncharged not convicted unarmed
individual
it was gross to say the least
and what you would expect from Fox News
uh didn't quite come to fruition I was
actually a little shocked at some of the
more reasonable takes than you would
expect
it didn't just devolve into just comply
and this won't happen
here's Jesse Waters while still sucking
up to police and showing deference for
police departments no matter what the
charges against them are
he still seems a little bothered by the
footage watch this
one mother lost four children four Sons
to homicide before the age of 30.
and so we just has to stop and these
officers uh black officers in a in a
black neighborhood they're working on a
crime task force and they had really
really made a lot of arrests from when
this task force was put up and running
in October and had really cleaned up the
streets but now to watch this
this is hard to see and I think we have
another tape again it's about two
minutes viewer warning another body cam
this is graphic watch he's almost there
he's almost there
they were working on a crime task force
and they had made a lot of arrests and
had to really they had really cleaned up
the streets but to watch this is It's
hard to see he says but he doesn't quite
get there he doesn't quite ask the right
questions of did they affect the arrests
they affected because of the fact that
used they used brutality and illegal
means to do so
are they not going to question that
these cops don't feel constrained by the
Constitution to which they sworn oath to
support and defend
Jesse Watters went on to have Heather
McDonald on who is uh protect the cops
at all costs
um
besmirch the the the prospect of
diversity training within police
departments of implicit bias training
and of course they go to her the expert
quote unquote and this is how that
devolved and then we're going to talk
about exactly how she's wrong with some
facts with some data with some research
let's bring in the author of War on Cops
we have Heather McDonald here Heather
take us out big picture statistically I
mean this is this is extremely rare
well absolutely and you know Jesse this
looks like absolutely terrible tactics
cops are desperate for more tactical
training and de-escalation and stress
control so they're not put in an in a
position that they feel they need to use
uh lethal force and instead they're
being given implicit bias training
diversity training complete waste of
money but the narrative that is being
put on what looks to be a very horrific
incident is inflammatory it's coming
from the president on down that we are
living through an epidemic of racially
biased police killings of black men that
is completely false President Biden just
said oh the the criminal justice system
denies equal treatment to blacks he
should know better study after study
coming out of Harvard out of Michigan
State University out of the left-wing
Center for policing Equity shows that
there is no bias in fatal police
shooting so Jesse Waters proclaims this
is extremely rare
I think we all know any of us who are
paying attention for for any amount of
time relative to the treatment of police
the civilians by police in the United
States especially related to the
treatment of unarmed black men is that
this isn't an exceedingly rare or
extremely rare as he categorized it it's
an all too common occurrence
and McDonald's saying that she blames
diversity training and implicit bias
training that we need more use of force
training that's what we need for police
and then she makes the Bold claim that
there was no racial bias there is no
racial bias in police in fatal police
shootings and this just flies in the
face
of what we know I'm going to read a
little bit from this Guardian article
just one paragraph here the guardian
article entitled if you want to read the
entire thing
it never stops killings by U.S police
reach record high in 2022 law
enforcement killed at least 1
176 people or about a hundred people a
month last year making it the deadliest
for police violence
and this is the paragraph
black people were 24 of those killed
last year while making up over only 13
percent of the population from 2013 to
2022 black residents were three times
more likely to be killed by U.S police
than white people the inequality is
particularly severe in some cities
including Minneapolis where where police
killed black residents at a rate 28
times higher than white residents and
Chicago where the rate was 25 times
higher
and that comes from mapping police
violence those statistics that I just
read you
so this this claim this bold Fox News
talking point is nothing but nonsense
and lies and and subterfuge
it is plain cute with actual crime
statistics and statistics related to
police brutality
mapping police violence also has this
chart
there's a racial disparity even in who
the police killed while they're running
away not the police
the the suspect
one in every three people killed by
police was running away driving away or
otherwise trying to flee black and brown
people were more likely to be killed
while fleeing
so
the nonsense that Fox News will try to
to perpetrate upon the American people
even in the wake of a brutal
gang style slain of a citizen is
remarkable Republicans are raw raw raw
on waiving their constitutions
they're rah-rah-rah about
anti-establishment
and the Deep State and being scared of
the government but when it comes to
Armed agents of the state
who brutally use the power they've been
granted their arrest power the power to
take the lives of citizens it's crickets
from the peanut gallery of conservative
the the hierarchy of conservative media
they protect the cops Law and Order they
say while calling in to question the
Integrity of government everywhere else
it doesn't make
any sense
the other
bizarre thing that happened this weekend
or it when the weekend started on Friday
was the more full picture that we saw of
the attack on Paul Pelosi Nancy Pelosi's
husband
and again not going to play the tape the
brutal attack the hammer attack on the
nearly octogenarian Paul Pelosi by David
depap
and David Papp the day that the footage
was released made a phone call to a
reporter at KTVU
and wanted to say sorry
now I'm going to read how KTVU
categorized the call
and then I'm going to play the call the
segment of the call that they've put
that they've made public
and it is remarkable
that the the the conspiracy theories
that were promoted by people like Megan
Kelly and elsewhere that there was all
kinds of uh conspiracies surrounding the
relationship that Paul Pelosi had with
this this guy which didn't exist and
then when we see it rather than have a
Maya culpa moment rather than them come
out and say oh we're really sorry we
were wrong
course that's not what they do
but this is this is this call is is uh
remarkable because it leads to again
when Republicans and conservatives use
the words talking about Liberty and
talking about tyranny
they do so knowing that it doesn't just
happen in a vacuum they do so knowing
that people like David de path and
others who who
um
exert violence in in some attempts to
overthrow the government or make a
change they know that their words don't
go forth void that there there is an end
game and some people are going to latch
on to that language to that rhetoric and
make violence happen
here's here's the description from KTVU
David depap called the T the KTVU
Newsroom this afternoon and told our
reporter he had an important message he
said he attacked Paul Pelosi because
people's individual liberties are under
attack in the chilling call he
apologized for not going further the
call came on the same day of the video
of the infamous Hammer attack on Paul
Pelosi was released here is that excerpt
from the call and then I want to talk
about that rhetoric once again okay so
what's what what do you want to say
because they really as you know they
released the video earlier today
yeah I saw that yes what what did you
want thank you for calling me what did
you want what did you want to tell me
um
for everyone in America
you're welcome
Liberty isn't dying
being killed systematically and
deliberately
the people killing it have names and
addresses
so I got their names and addresses so I
could pay them a little visit I have a
heart-to-heart chat about their bad
behavior
the capability needs watering
you've been a Fowler Patriots willing to
put their own lives on the line to stand
in oppositions
I would also like to apologize
I want to apologize to everyone I messed
up
what I did was really bad I'm so sorry I
didn't get more of them it's my own
fault no one else is to blame I should
have got better prepared I spent all my
Time Explosion government corruption
online only to have them silence
countries must eat as quickly as they
could they circumvented the constitution
in the Private Industry
moving class outsources the recession of
your civil rights to Private Industry
it's called fascism
I have a lot more to say I had a website
of over 300 pages
that's 300 pages of stuff they don't
want you to hear
I'm in the process of trying to set up a
new site out of the reach of tyrannical
Global homeostasis on their internet
sensors
many of you know I grew up in a white
Christian nationalist household that was
my faith tradition I grew up in northern
Idaho amidst separatist types militia
type people at the very least people who
admired the militiamen
and there these this language was all
over the place growing up and that that
line there you that you might not be
familiar with when him talking about
um the tree of Liberty needs watering
there's a quote somewhere about the the
the the the tree of Liberty needing
watered by the blood of patriots
and he's referring there to he didn't go
far enough he didn't he didn't uh attack
or or kidnap which was his plan Nancy
Pelosi more he he didn't he should have
done more people he should have attacked
more people and for him this is the
watering of the tree of Liberty giving
up his freedom to a larger cause
in this language that Republicans use
that conservative use the Ted Cruzes the
Matt Gates's the Paul gosars the the
entire Freedom caucus they all talk like
this
and they know what the result is that
it's going to whip up a certain
percentage of the audience of their fan
base in the cult
who are going to take matters into their
own hands they're not going to sit idly
by while their country is being
destroyed
they're going to do something about it
of course I say country being destroyed
tongue-in-cheek because that is not at
all what's happening
they have been convinced of election
fraud on a wide
conspiracy-laden basis
and if your country is being taken from
you if it's being invaded at the
southern border and nothing's being done
you take matters into your own hands
or at least they do
this is all dangerous but you're not
going to see Republicans uh change their
messaging you're not going to see them
change their ways because it works for
them the the results don't matter to
them the violence that is brought upon
innocent people doesn't matter to them
the insurrections that have happened in
the past and that may come to pass again
don't matter to Republicans they don't
matter
because power is what matters as long as
they stay in office as long as they're
able to try to implement and continue to
implement
a usurpation of our constitutional
rights the women's right to choose
marriage equality a host of other civil
liberty issues
they're going to keep at it
it is it is it is time for America and
well-intended
country-loving liberals to
swarm the polls because the only way
that this is going to change is through
activism and organization to overwhelm
them at the at the polling station that
is is what it's going to do
because we are obviously not going to be
using the same
violence-inducing tactics that they do
speaking of the fecklessness of
Republicans and their inability to do
the right thing in the face of uh
wrongdoing
of Lies
uh George Santos this he's the gift that
keeps on giving it is crazy to me that
more is not being said of Republic by
Republicans uh that there's not a
movement afoot to at least Reign this
guy in and now because uh of of intrepid
reporters doing investigative work we're
finding out that it is likely that
there's there is a there there it is
likely that he is going to find his day
in court and maybe be removed I I think
it's unlikely I think that the
investigation and any prosecution that
would take place would would take far
longer than his term in office for this
two years but the the Mother Jones just
did a piece about his his donor base and
they looked at his
his several of his donors in the 2020
election
many of which dozens maybe they they
don't exist they can't find these people
and I'm going to read kind of a
summation here from The Daily Beast but
you really should go seek out this
article from from Mother Jones because
it is detailed and they go through who
the names are and what their addresses
are and they tried to reach out some of
these addresses don't even exist some of
the people they did reach out to who did
answer the phone who do exist said we
didn't give that money
and so the question is because the money
was given
just not by the people
that the names were listed so who gave
the money and why did they give the
money to get this nut
in office
people don't just give freely of their
treasure
to get George Santos elected without
getting something in return
and these are all questions that are
coming out I mean look we all laughed we
all made our jokes about him lying about
his mother dying on 9 11 about her dying
on the 23rd of December and that was her
fifth year anniversary about him having
two knee Replacements and being a
volleyball star at a college he didn't
go to about his name being Anthony De
volder all of the insane lies that he
told that were absolutely most certainly
going to be found out
but this goes to a different level of
corruption and criminality allegedly
likely I believe and getting to the
bottom of this is important now you
can't rely upon Republicans to do that
because Kevin McCarthy gave him
committee assignments gave him more
credibility more legitimacy
but I'm going to read this summation
from The Daily Beast here some of George
Santos top donors apparently don't even
exist report sets more than a dozen
major donations to George Santos 2020
Congressional Campaign came from donors
who appear to not exist according to an
investigation by Mother Jones
Santos Congressional Campaign reported
in 2020 that Victoria and Jonathan Reger
Had Each maxed out by contributing 2 800
to his campaign
but no one in the United States has
either name according to the report and
the address listed also doesn't exist
more than thirty thousand dollars of the
money raised for Santos's campaign came
from people who don't appear to exist
although it's illegal to donate money to
a campaign under a false name one donor
who told Mother Jones he's a friend of
Santos said he didn't make the 2800
donation Santos listed on his FEC filing
the questionable funding reveal comes as
the FEC considers a criminal probe of
Santos over his newly listed campaign
Treasurer who has claimed he isn't
actually the congressman's treasurer
now this is the 2020 campaign
when they start digging my guess would
be he didn't get any more clear
or accurate in his campaign filings we
already know that he was filing dozens
and dozens and dozens and dozens of
campaign expenditures that were just
under the limit before he had to provide
a receipt
199.99 there were dozens of them for
Uber rides one whole day of uber rides
uh of of 200
199.99 the next day another
199.99 in Uber rides in flights in trip
insurance in restaurants in just a
panoply
of lies from George Santos so this
a case of a guy who lied about his
background There's real questions real
things to find out related to how he got
his money who gave it to him and what
they want for it
we'll certainly continue to follow this
case as journalists do the good work of
investigating wrongdoing
by this particular clown
once again I am Jesse dollar Moore host
of dollymore daily on YouTube you can
catch me on Twitter at Dollar Moore and
uh you listen to my podcast I doubt it
on anywhere that podcasts are found
we're also on Twitter there I doubt it
podcast thanks for joining me
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
my name is Jesse dollar Moore and I'm
sitting in for David Pacman while he is
out
Donald Trump's campaign kicked off in
Earnest it seems this weekend he was in
New Hampshire and South Carolina and a
lot of what you would expect from Donald
Trump took place in both events what it
shows me really is that it's going to be
even crazier this year than in 2016 or
in 2020 because his entire strategy has
changed surrounding campaign events so
it appears they're far more small and
intimate some would say that it's just
to mix things up but I think the any
Observer with any Acumen or
understanding of politics or Donald
Trump for that matter is really going to
understand it as a diminished support
from people in the party people are
tired of the games and the tricks and
the uh the over-the-top nonsense but
rather than change fundamentally how he
acts and what he does is it's a tertiary
change it's just a surface level
um
difference in how he's running things
because all of the craziness all of the
loopiness all of the lies all of the
insanity is still there in his New
Hampshire speech
he made this bold claim
about how if he were president or if he
becomes president he will end this
Ukraine thing in 24 hours
watch this
guy's gonna be in World remember crooked
Hillary he's going to cause a war in his
first week in office because they think
that's my personality type it's actually
the opposite my personality kept us out
of War
and I told you before would have never
happened with Russia would have never
gone to Putin would have never ever gone
in
and even now I could solve that in 24
hours it's so horrible what happened in
those cities are demolished now the
people I'll bet you have millions it
could be millions of you how can you you
know they bomb a city to the ground
these big buildings come tumbling down
they say two people were injured not two
people
they lie I mean they lie but
if I were president you would have zero
chance that that war would have happened
that is telling and quite interesting
considering the fact that just about a
year ago
February 2022 Donald Trump was on the
the clay Travis and Buck Sexton show
they all went down to Mar-A-Lago to have
a good time on their podcast and he said
all kinds of glowing things about
Vladimir Putin he called him genius he
called him Savvy he called wonderful
it's insinuated he was a peacekeeper
remember this Mo keep in mind what you
just watched with him saying he would
solve this problem in Ukraine
remembering a look back to one year ago
with all of the things that he said
about Ukraine and Vladimir Putin uh I've
never seen anything like it I've I don't
think our country has ever been so low
you could take the five worst Presidents
in the history of our country and put
them together I don't think they've done
the damage that this Administration has
done Mr President in the last 24 hours
we know Russia has said that they are
recognizing two Breakaway regions of
Ukraine and now this White House is
stating that this is in Invasion that's
the strong word what went wrong here
what is the current occupant of the Oval
Office done that he could have done
differently
well what went wrong was a rigged
election and what went wrong as a
candidate that shouldn't be there and a
man that has no concept of what he's
doing I went in yesterday and there was
a television screen and I said this is
genius
Putin declares a big portion of the
Ukraine of Ukraine Putin declares it as
independent oh that's wonderful so Putin
is now saying it's independent a large
section of Ukraine I said how smart is
that and he's going to go in and be a
peacekeeper
that's the strongest peace for us we
could use that on our Southern border
that's the strongest peace Force I've
ever seen there were more army tanks
than I've ever seen they're going to
keep peace all right no but think of it
here's a guy who's very Savvy I know him
very well very very well by the way this
never would have happened with us had
I've been in office not even thinkable
this would never have happened but
here's a guy that says you know I'm
going to declare
a big portion of Ukraine independent he
used the word independent and we're
going to go out and we're going to go in
and we're going to help keep peace you
got to say that's pretty Savvy and you
know what the response was from Biden
there was no response
he calls him a genius
it's wonderful what took place how smart
is that calls him a peacekeeper and the
strongest peace Force
does that sound like a man who's going
to run in as president of the United
States and solve the Ukraine problem in
24 hours this coming from the same guy
who was going to have infrastructure
week week after week after week after
week and it never got done until Joe
Biden took office
this coming from the guy who's going to
build the wall
that everything was just about to happen
never getting anything done other than
massive unpaid for tax cuts that
contributed to him adding 25 or taking
responsibility for
not taking responsibility for but being
responsible for 25 or so of our total
overall national debt inside of
four years the other part this little
clip I want to share is him talking
about how he invented the word Caravan
and he tells his rich friends who aren't
citizens who want to be citizens that
what they need to do is just cross the
border and then they'll just magically
be declared citizens I guess by the
federal government
watch this astounding misunderstanding
or just lies being told by Donald Trump
to give you a flavor for what's to come
in this campaign cycle
and I came up with the name Caravan
because we had Caravans of 15 20 000
people pouring in uh not when I I tell
you what we had it stopped pretty early
but now if you look at these Caravans
these are massive massive Caravans and
they have no idea who these people are
coming into our country they're walking
in unabated there's nothing that
nobody's asking them about health or
it's hard to get in I have so many
people can you help me become a citizen
I say yeah go to the southern border
just walk across the line you know I
have a guy rich guy wants to become a
citizen and he's gone through everything
he's gone to school to study and this
and this and that he's been working for
11 years he hasn't been able to pull it
off okay
and I finally said to him you know
you've been working so hard why don't
you just
go down to Mexico
and sort of start walking across our
border
they'll take you gladly they won't even
talk to you now how ridiculous it is
like lots that Donald Trump does and
says it starts off as kind of a joke and
then his free association leads him to
tell a story that is almost certainly
untrue
uh but with a serious tone and tenor to
it he's not telling telling it like it's
a joke he he he got serious there for a
moment
he's telling people
that he believes the way to do it as
though we're just issuing citizenship to
anyone who crosses the southern border
the issue of immigration in this country
is is such a uh a murky topic because of
the lies that are told by the right
because of the lies and the the abject
just white nationalism that has infected
a massive swath of our country they talk
about it like it's an invasion they talk
about it like there's an impending War
that's going to take place it gets the
psychos in the Republican Party whipped
up into a frenzy
and all that does is exacerbate the
problem because they're not there to
solve it there's no evidence whatsoever
that Kevin McCarthy or anyone in
leadership in the Republican Party in
the House of Representatives wants to
solve the problem they want to continue
to be a political football they want it
to continue
to to
make hay for them be a be a campaign
slogan it's a prop to them they're not
there to solve problems and it's just
getting worse and worse and worse as
time goes on
South Carolina Donald Trump
after leaving New Hampshire moved on to
South Carolina to another
minuscule campaign event inside the
South Carolina State Capitol it is
it's telling we're gonna have to witness
what takes place in the coming months
with his what he chooses to do with his
rallies because for all of the of the
the mocking he did of Joe Biden not
being able to fill Arenas or whatever
all the mocking that he's done of
Hillary Clinton
he's now taking that it's it's a lot a
lot it's along the same lines as when he
was making fun of every politician for
reading from a teleprompter and then
shifted and did the exact same thing
it's okay for him to read from a
teleprompter but it's absolutely
mockable if someone else does it so he
went to South Carolina
at first actually let me give you a
flavor for just how small these events
are compared to 2016 when he was filling
these these rally event
um uh venues just with thousands of
people this is what he's dealing with
now
[Music]
the president who can take on the whole
system
and the president that can win a really
great last time he got 12 million more
votes than we did the time before
somebody interviewed me recently what
was the difference between 2020 and 2016
they said the difference is we did much
better in 2020 we didn't have many
millions or more votes but we got to be
careful on Election Day
and while I was just wanted to show you
a flavor for the campaign event did you
hear what he was saying there that you
need a president who can take on the
whole system you need a president who
can win
says the loser who never got who never
won the popular vote one single time
in fact this last time when he lost the
election even the Electoral College
7 million plus votes he lost by but he's
the president who can win
it's utter delusion from Donald Trump
and speaking of utter delusion
Lindsey Graham it wouldn't be a South
Carolina campaign event without Lindsey
Graham there just hovering just lap
dogging it just boot licking Donald
Trump just without shame with every time
there's Donald Trump and Lindsey Graham
on stage it is sure to be a dignity-free
performance watch this from Lindsey
Graham
well he did it once he can do it again
and now while we're here
so Mr President I started my political
career right there
and I got my first paycheck and I said I
gotta get out of here to the State House
people you're not doing it for the money
there's one thing I want to talk to you
about
how many
how many times have you heard we like
Trump
uh policies but we want somebody new
there are no Trump policies without
Donald Trump
I was there
no Trump policies without Donald Trump
says Lindsey Graham
there's a lot of candidates actually who
are in the race and coming out of the
woodwork to maybe run for president
we've got Mike pempeo kind of circling
around writing his book getting his name
out there Mike Pence is reportedly
exploring a run we've got Ron DeSantis
who's being clamored about in Republican
circles and Nikki Haley the former
governor of South Carolina and on the
plane ride to one of these events Donald
Trump was asked about Rhonda and Ron
DeSantis entering the ring about Nikki
Haley entering the ring and in his
warped brain he believes that because he
got Ron DeSantis elected it's disloyal
of Ron DeSantis to then run against
Donald Trump and something similar he
said about Nikki Haley watch this
wants to do take a listen to what he
said
Iran would have not been governor
before that very disloyal
for a little while but I said look you
know go by your heart if you want to run
she's publicly stated I would never run
against my president he was a great
president
that's not how it works Donald Trump
first of all you didn't get DeSantis
elected he certainly sucked up
campaign ads with his baby and with a
make America great against Trump
campaign sign yeah it's all very
incestuous within the Republican Party
and speaking of that
that was an unintended an unintended
Segway the Republican Party
is also in a bad boat
Mike Lindell
Kerry Lake
did this very off-the-wall interview
with Steve Bannon they were at the the
Republican winter meeting where they
re-elected Rana Romney McDaniel to be
chairperson of the Republican National
Committee the National Committee she's
once again the chair of
and this came to Great consternation for
the the my pillow goof who wanted he he
was in the running along with a lawyer
out of San Francisco Maine named Harmony
Dillon
and uh they both lost to to Rana Romney
McDaniel
she she lost the Romney because Donald
Trump didn't like it but I you know I'm
just that penny I'm going to continue to
call her Rana Romney McDaniel but this
this clip that I'm going to play for you
of the the Bannon interviewing both
Carrie Lake and Mike Lindell sitting
side by side is just bizarre and it's
not bizarre for the fact that the
background is actually more blurry than
Carrie Lake's face usually is it's
bizarre because they're doing the thing
that I've been talking about uh very
recently but also four months that the
rhetoric surrounding not having a
country anymore the rhetoric surrounding
our Republic being just a failed State
the rhetoric surrounding us losing our
sovereignty is being whipped up into a
frenzy by these particular Fringe clowns
watch this
Ronald
McDaniel has not you've been there for
three days Ronald McDaniel has not
pulled you aside and said let's have a
cup of coffee and spend five minutes
together have you guys spent any time
with each other one-on-one
no we have an unfortunate and and you
know what I do want to reach out to her
because here's what's going on and I
know that this might not be the popular
View
Rana one
and full stop full stop you should you
shouldn't have to reject you shouldn't
have to reach out to Ronald McDaniel
you're the freaking governor of Arizona
you just won an incredibly tough race
because you stood for policies that Maga
stands for she should be blowing your
phone up every day can I get five
minutes this is outrageous but but
here's what I'm willing to do I'm
willing to meet with her and say let's
move forward because this next election
if we do not get president Donald Trump
back in the white house I don't know how
much longer we can last I think our
Republic is in Peril I will do
everything in my power if that means I
can't across the country whatever it
means I want to get president Trump
if we don't get you in Arizona if we
don't get you in Arizona now I'm not
going to sure we have sovereignty
all of that is alarming because one
they're just leaning into the conspiracy
theory that Kerry Lake won the election
you shouldn't have to wait for Ronda Ron
McDaniel to call you you're the governor
of of Arizona
It's News to the rest of the country
Steve Bannon Steve Bannon who has has
his hands in the attempted coup in
Brazil Steve Bannon who had his hand
deeply in to the Insurrection at the
United States Capitol on January 6 2021.
the attempted overthrow of the United
States government partly many believe
orchestrated planned and executed by
Steve Bannon and his colleagues
and here he is again trying to whip up
the base by using language like this and
she doesn't jettison it she doesn't
swatted away she Embraces it
this next election if we don't get
Donald Trump back in the white house I
don't know how much longer we can last
I think our Republic is in Peril she
says
that that is strong language that whips
clowns like David depap the guy who was
talking about the the tree of Liberty
needing watered by the blood of patriots
is what would follow
it's those types of people who have
violent tendencies who have a proclivity
to to radicalism they're going to be
animated by language like this
and he shuts her down on the Trump thing
he says no no no if we don't get you in
Arizona now I'm not sure we're going to
have sovereignty
all of this is problematic and all of
this should should animate you
to want to make a difference in this
upcoming election look I know it seems
like oh we just got through the midterms
2024 is too far away to really worry
about that it is not you need to talk to
your friends to your neighbors to your
family to your co-workers hell to the
dude you sit next to it the bus stop and
talk to them about this type of thing
because if we can animate one person
each and they can animate one person we
can overwhelm Republicans at the polls
to ensure that we don't lose our
sovereignty that we don't lose our
Republic that it absolutely is in Peril
but not for the reasons that Carrie Lake
says
once again I am Jesse dollimore thank
you for joining me you can follow me on
Twitter I am at Dollar Moore there and
Twitter and Instagram and Tick Tock I'm
on uh YouTube dollymore daily or just
search my stupid name you'll find me
there I'd love to have you subscribe and
uh be a regular Watcher of my mouth that
flaps in my face that gets red when I
get angry
anyway I'll see you next time thanks a
lot
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show welcome
back to the David Pacman show I Am David
packman if he was
a giant elf who got stung by a thousand
bees in the neck and then swelled up and
became this monstrosity before you
cities there's another unplanned segue
I'm becoming very good at those
Mike Uh Kevin McCarthy not Mike McCarthy
that's a that's a different person who
coaches football Kevin McCarthy Speaker
of the House of Representatives of these
United States there's a lot of words
that come to mind when you think about
Kevin McCarthy Integrity is not one that
comes to mind
intelligent is not one that comes to
mind necessarily
but uh
sycophantic is and a tool a useful idiot
for Radicals in Congress certainly comes
to mind he was on with Margaret
um Brennan yesterday on Face the Nation
and gave a disastrous
performance just a disastrous interview
with Margaret Brennan
and he was asked many many questions
some of which he he faked like he
answered he has this new thing that he
does when when he's answering a question
with with an answer that isn't an answer
to the actual question he says why man
let me answer your question the way I
say I'm going to answer the question he
he's that's his new tack is to become
like aggressive guy
and he's asked two things we're going to
play two clips here one is about George
Santos
and about whether or not he should be
expelled from the body because you need
two-thirds of the House of
Representatives to vote to expel him as
a member
they're not going to do that because
they've got a Democrat Governor in New
York a number of different reasons that
are at play here but the other thing
he's asked about is about Marjorie
Taylor green being placed on the coveted
Origins committee to investigate that
the same woman who believes wearing a
mask is like the treatment of the Jews
during the Holocaust
the same woman who calls into question
every sudden death as vaccine linked a
woman who believes 911 was a hoax a
woman who believes Jews have lasers in
space aimed at California to fire a
laser and start a forest fire this is a
woman who has been elevated to the house
oversight committee and others of
importance she went from having no
committees at all
to some of the most elevated and sought
after committee assignments in the
entire house and you you would ask
yourself how is that when she spoke
nothing but poison into the ear of Kevin
McCarthy and about Kevin McCarthy and
all of a sudden their their thick as
thieves their Pals they're taking
selfies together on the floor of the
house
it's a valid question that should be
asked
and it was asked by Margaret Brennan and
this is what took place these These are
members who just got elected by their
constituents and we put them into
committees and I'm proud to do it let me
ask you about some specifics and
um Marjorie Taylor green you put her on
a new subcommittee to investigate the
origins of covet yes she compared mask
requirements to the type of abuse Jews
were subjected to during the Holocaust
she called for fauci to be arrested and
imprisoned and she spread conspiracy
theories how's anyone supposed to take
that work seriously and find that we're
credible very well you look at all of it
so you have all the questions out there
I think with the Americans you think
these are legitimate questions I think
with American public wants to see is an
open dialogue in the process this is a
select committee where people can have
all the questions they want and you'll
see the outcome
um those are nonsense answers from Kevin
McCarthy that we need to all the
questions need to be asked no they don't
not all questions are on the same level
Kevin McCarthy not all questions are
valid of the work of a of a of a special
Select Committee in the House of
Representatives open dialogue we're just
asking questions this is this is the
work of conspiracy theory this is how
they act this is what they say well
we're just asking questions what's wrong
with asking questions
and when you put someone like this as
pernicious and Sinister and indeed
stupid as Marjorie Taylor green on this
committee it diminishes the work that
they will do but again it doesn't matter
to Republicans but they're not in it for
credible findings they're in it for the
theater of it they're in it for the show
of it
now I was going to play this other clip
first but I I chose to do it second and
that is his absolute refusal to answer
the question about getting rid of George
Santos or what they're going to do at
all instead he starts talking about
proxy voting and the house being broken
and when she forces him or tries
attempts to make a force to him to
answer the question
he's not having it he's doing that thing
that I talked about earlier
watch this
but doesn't it further wear down
credibility when you put someone who's
under State local Federal and
international investigation as a
representative
I'm talking about George Santos uh
representative from New York we should
have that discussion so let's have that
discussion you want to bring up Santos
and let's talk about the institution
itself because I agree wholeheartedly
that Congress is broken and I think you
I think your listeners or viewers should
understand what proxy voting was because
it never took place but I'm asking about
George Santos I know you asked me a
question let me ask because you could
put it to a vote you asked me a question
I'd appreciate if you let me answer so
let's go through this because it's not
one simple answer Congress is broken
based upon what is transpired in the
last Congress the American public wasn't
able to come in to see us
people voted by proxy meaning you didn't
have to show up for work bills didn't go
have to go through committee so what I'm
trying to do is open the people's house
back for the people so their voice is
there so people are held accountable so
now as I just had in the last week for
the first time in seven years every
member got through it if you got a third
of your caucus to vote to ask him you
could do so do you don't think you could
get your Republicans to do that I wasn't
finished answering the question so if
every single new person brought into
Congress was elected by their
constituents what their constituents
have done has lend their voice to the
American public so those members can all
serve on committee now what I'm trying
to do is change some of these committees
as well like the Intel committee is
different than so you're just not going
to answer the question I asked well no I
no you don't get to question whether I
answer it you asked a question I'm
trying to get I don't think you've said
the name George Santos like once
but you know what I'm talking about
prophecies but no you started the
question with Congress was broken and I
agreed with you no but I was answering
the question of how Congress is broken
and how we're changing it so if I can
finish the question that you asked me
how Congress is broken I equated every
single member they just got elected by
their by their constituents they have a
right to serve so that means that Santos
can serve on a committee the same way
swalwell who had a relationship with a
Chinese spy but they will not serve on
Intel
because that's unfortunate I wish I
could answer the question I would love
to have you back I would love to be able
to come back and have time to answer the
question
not smart listen there are skilled
politicians who are very Adept at doing
the thing that Kevin McCarthy wishes he
could do which is you're asked a
question and you answer an entirely
different question and then it just
moves on
he's not good at it instead he gets
called out blatantly over like well
you're just not going to answer the
question then and he doesn't he
filibusters for for just about two
minutes in that space
refusing to answer the easiest of
questions
and you know what it's going to catch
him because George Santos and all the
investigations that are taking place
relative to financial impropriety to
campaign Finance impropriety it's going
to come back and his innocent until
proven guilty thing isn't going to play
anymore
when George Santos eventually
possibly
gets convicted of these crimes and they
are crimes some of the things that he's
being accused of now it's not just he
lied about his mom dying on 911 as
Despicable as that is it's not just
lying about being a volleyball star with
replaced knees
there are serious issues that Kevin
McCarthy isn't qualified isn't capable
and has no desire to try to get to the
bottom of
the other thing in the news
related to impropriety and not getting
things done is the Supreme Court you
famously this summer there was a draft
opinion leaked that told the world that
the Supreme Court was going to overturn
Roe v Wade
and in subsequent months there's been an
investigation and I use heavy heavy air
quotes there an investigation to get to
the bottom of what took place and then
just a few days ago it came out that
though
we're we can't find the leaker we don't
know investigation over even though they
didn't interview any of the actual
justices everybody else involved had to
sign sworn affidavits under the penalty
of perjury that they were telling the
truth they had nothing to do with it but
the justices didn't nor did the
Justice's family because there is no
code of ethics there's no code of
conduct for the Supreme Court people who
make decisions that impact the lives of
360 million Americans aren't held to the
same standards that you are at your job
I'm going to read a little bit from the
CNN article entitled exclusive Supreme
Court did not disclose Financial
relationship with expert brought in to
review leak probe the Supreme Court did
not disclose its long-standing Financial
ties with former Homeland Security
secretary Michael chertoff even as it
touted him as an expert who
independently validated its
investigation into who leaked the draft
opinion overturning Roe v Wade the
Court's inquiry released last week with
chertoff's endorsement failed to
identify who was responsible for the
unprecedented leak the decision to keep
the relationship with church off quiet
is a reflection of a pattern of opacity
at the nation's highest court whose
rulings affect every American
now this relationship is worth a million
or so dollars to Michael chertoff
they pay him the court pays him has paid
his firm about a million dollars so the
reason that this stinks is the fact that
he has an incentive he has a motive to
do the bidding of the Supreme Court and
sign off on this BS investigation
because if he goes the other way if he
goes against the court that money very
well could dry up
I believe the days of holding and high
esteem the Supreme Court of the United
States are over
it is an absolute activist Maga Court
you've got your your Neil Gorsuch your
Sam Alito your Clarence Thomas your
Brett Kavanaugh John Roberts used to be
one of the worst and now he looks like a
good guy in comparison
it is terrible and they're Shameless
about it they have no I mean the mask is
off they don't care if you know
I'm going to continue reading here CNN
has learned from sources familiar with
the arrangements that the court in
recent years has privately contracted
with the shirt off the chertoff group
excuse me for security assessments some
broadly covering Justice's safety and
some specifically related to covid-19
protocols at the court itself the
estimated payments to his risk
assessment firm for consultations that
extended over several months and
involved a review of the justices homes
reached at least a million dollars
and here we go again no transparency or
opacity as CNN said it the exact amount
of money paid could not be determined
Supreme Court contracts are not covered
by federal public disclosure rules and
elude tracking on public databases they
don't have to follow the same rules that
even Congress does and Congress doesn't
have to follow the same rules that the
rest of the country does
the justices have long cloaked
themselves in secrecy to the point of
declining to respond to questions about
potential conflicts of interest or to
reveal information about some court
rules and ethics codes or to release
timely information about the Justice's
health and public appearances
this is all gross
if they want to to maintain some air of
credibility we need
a code of ethics for the Supreme Court
and how we get that is Congress
in the Constitution Congress is given
the power to organize the courts they
could do this they could have done it
last Congress they could have done it
the Congress before they could have done
it the Congress before but they sit on
their hands because it is not in their
best interest to wreck to to to to to to
rock the boat
it's it's all
a bit much
again I would love to see you subscribe
to me on YouTube Jesse dollar more
follow me on social media I'm at Dollar
Moore on on Instagram on Twitter and
tick tock
I'd love to see you there
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
welcome back to the David Pacman show I
am Jesse dalamore host of The dollamore
Daily on the YouTubes
listen Fox News if they're good at
anything it is running interference for
Republicans it's running interference
maybe chiefly for Donald Trump
and they will continue their lies about
Republican policy for as long as they
can and this doesn't just come from the
infra the the in the infotainment side
the entertainment side of Fox News your
Tucker Carlson's your your Laura ingrams
your Sean hannities it all it also comes
from the the news side Harris Faulkner
is who I'm going to talk about today
uh right now there's a budget battle
there's the the debt ceiling fight that
we're in the threat to shut down the
government and there's a lot of talk
about where this debt came from and
who's responsible for this debt
and Republicans would have you believe
that they are all all about being good
stewards of the people's money being
being responsible Spenders and making
sure that everything's paid for
all while supporting Donald Trump and
getting in bed with Donald Trump and his
insane tax cuts for the rich that took
place in 2017 or so
that led to one to one and a half
trillion dollar deficits every year of
his presidency and that was before covet
that was before all of the supplemental
spending that took place around that
so when they talk about the deficit I
want to say this up front before you
hear her propaganda and her Lies when
they talk about all the Democrats just
want to spend spend spend
but they don't tell you that Donald
Trump himself
in one term is responsible for roughly
25 of the entire national debt of the
United States a man who in like 2015 or
2016 prior to being elected to office
gave an interview with Bob Woodward at
the Washington Post and made the Bold
claim that he was going to pay off the
entire national debt inside of eight
years and instead he's now responsible
for 25 percent of the overall debt but
you wouldn't know that if you only
watched Fox News if your parents are
people who watch Fox News is your
grandparents are people who watch Fox
News they'll buy this Hook Line and
Sinker the same way Americans bought the
trickle-down economics Works Reaganomics
oh it's a godsend that's how that's how
you build back a strong economy it's all
lies and it gets told over and over and
over and over again to the point where
people start believing it in the face of
insurmountable evidence that it is false
and history for that matter watch Harris
Faulkner selling a just vile Sinister
lie here
at issue the money is coming out of the
programs faster than it's going in the
Congressional budget office reports
Social Security is headed for bankruptcy
without legislative action to save it it
looks like it will run dry within the
next 10 years that would automatically
cut benefits by 23 percent for every
single American
who needs those programs Medicare
funding is Vanishing even faster the
timing of all of this of trying to
figure out what to do comes during a
fierce battle as you know it's happening
in our nation's capital over spending
the debt growing precipitously the
standoff between Republican lawmakers
and the White House over raising the
borrowing limit Democrats want to do
what they do spin spin spend Republicans
want to slash and save
Democrats want to do what they do
spend spend spend and Republicans want
to slash and Save
you think Harris Faulkner do you think
that's what's Happening Here
Republicans want to they want to slash
and Save
while we have a nearly one trillion
dollar military budget every single year
listen I spent many years in the United
States Marine Corps proud I'm proud of
my service
but we don't need a trillion dollar
annual defense budget because what's
what are we defending
there is no there there's not a massive
war taking place we don't need to fund
the conflict
a thousand billion dollars every single
year year in and year out
but Republicans are responsible with the
money
they want to reorganize Social Security
they want to raise the retirement age
it is all
gross and Sinister because people fall
for it
most importantly it's bad because of
that because they have a captive
audience with their their their their
aging out audience of Boomers who
believe this crap
shame on you Paris Faulkner shame on you
the other thing that there is shame to
be talked about is on federal
prosecutors I have been talking on my
own channel for
years now about consequence for Donald
Trump in the wake of the attempted
overthrow of the United States
government the Insurrection the failed
coup attempt
by way of overturning a free and fair
election
they could prosecute that they could
have prosecuted obstruction of justice
the multiple cases of obstruction of
justice outlined in the Mueller report
they didn't and in this case they could
have prosecuted the hush money payments
made to Stormy Daniels but instead
prosecutors and I'm going to read a
little bit from this instead prosecutors
thought oh this this will seem small in
comparison to all of the insane treason
and other crimes of Donald Trump we're
just not going to bring this
and this is a problem
Justice should be met Justice should be
served no matter if you think it's a
small matter and something along
something else will come along
get past the buck to someone else when
you have a prosecutable crime before you
reading from the CNN article Federal
prosecutors discussed charging Trump and
Stormy Daniels case when he left office
book says days before then president
Donald Trump left the White House
Federal prosecutors in New York
discussed whether to potentially charge
Trump with campaign Finance crimes once
he was out of office according to a new
book from senior CNN legal analyst Ellie
honig prosecutors from the southern
district of New York developed
significant evidence against Trump when
they charged his former attorney Michael
Cohen in 2018 over a hush money scheme
paying two women claiming affairs with
Trump including adult film star Stormy
Daniels honig writes but prosecutors did
not consider charging Trump at the time
because of long-standing justice
department guidance that a sitting
president cannot be indicted I hope you
caught that I hope you caught that one
line in there that they
developed significant evidence against
Trump when they charged his former
attorney and then eventually had a
conviction for Michael Cohen
they had evidence
and they chose not to prosecute
this is this is a failure of the United
States justice department this is a
failure of Justice in general it should
be dispassionate he committed a crime
you convict you investigate you
prosecute and you secure a conviction
I understand that the office of legal
counsel within the Department of Justice
has a long-standing memo this isn't law
this is an opinion within a division of
the Department of Justice that says you
can't charge a sitting president that is
nonsense and many experts agree
continuing with the article here with
Trump about to leave office in January
2021 however
Audrey Strauss the acting U.S attorney
held multiple discussions with a small
group of prosecutors to discuss its
evidence against Trump they decided to
not seek an indictment of trump for
several reasons honig writes including
the political ramifications and the fact
that Trump's other scandals such as
efforts to overturn the 2020
presidential election and the January 6
2021 Insurrection made the campaign
Finance violation seems somehow trivial
and outdated by comparison
what
the crime was committed was it not you
secured a conviction with someone
involved with the crime why would you
let Donald Trump off the hook
it is it laziness
what is it
it's malpractice
as far as I'm concerned
continuing here quote we were well aware
of the Prudential reasons why you
wouldn't charge a president even after
he was out of office while Federal
prosecutors in New York opted not to
pursue their case against Donald Trump
Manhattan district attorney Alvin Bragg
appears to be looking into the matter
again Cohen met this month with
prosecutors from his office the first
such meeting in more than a year and the
clearest sign to date that the Manhattan
district attorney is zirien in on the
Trump organization's involvement in the
husk money payments so look look
I've said this going back in the days
after the Insurrection that we are going
to have to rely upon journalists and
people writing books
for uh the investigatory work to be done
because Federal prosecutors they're not
up to it in my estimation
Merrick Garland has sat on his hands
under the guise of well we want to be
thorough
and slow paced in in our in in our
investigation that we want to do this
the right way and sober minded
we don't need to drag our feet until Joe
Biden isn't President anymore and then
the entire thing is scuttled
and here we have further evidence that
they just decided not to prosecute
because oh there's bigger things
Republicans right now want to talk about
a two-tier justice system in the United
States Joe Biden's not being treated the
same way as Donald Trump about the
documents
none of that is true but that's not what
two-tiered is they're both presidents
that's one tear
it's that if I committed the same crimes
as Donald Trump I'd be sitting my ass in
a prison right now but because he's rich
because he's an ex-president because he
has powerful connections he gets a pass
and federal prosecutors gave him that
pass it's all
too much
I'd love to know what you think let's
mix it up in the comments
and uh follow me you can subscribe to my
YouTube channel jessiedollamore or
follow me on
um Twitter Instagram Tick Tock at dollar
more I'd love to see you there thanks a
lot for joining me today
foreign